one of the key tenants of scaling your
applications is automation well a
critter Junction embrace infrastructure
as code stay tuned to find out in the
last episode we learned about critter
junctions newfound popularity while
they've traditionally run on premise
they've just started port workloads and
rapidly spin up new servers in the cloud
see they're used to the classic approach
to infrastructure creation but was to
file a ticket somebody would log into a
management portal and go through a
series of steps to provision that piece
of infrastructure this works if you have
a relatively small footprint or if the
turn of your infrastructure is minimal
which was usually the case with critter
junctions private data centers a VM
would live for months to years with a
limited scale of deployment but now with
cloud elasticity beams can and should
live shorter lives they no longer have
fixed costs with depreciating Hardware
instead you pay per second minute or
hour the challenge here is delivering a
great user experience even if demand
spikes being able to rapidly spin of
resources and spin them back down is a
make-it-or-break-it for both cost
optimization and user experience but for
career junction manually filing tickets
and trying to reproduce infrastructure
at scale has been time-consuming and
human error prone if a spike occurs it
can take hours or even months to
provision infrastructure and time plus
it was hard to track and audit changes
this is where infrastructure as code I a
C comes into play
it's a technique to treat your
infrastructure provisioning and
configuration in the same way you handle
application codes you can automate
provisioning of your cloud resources
with code create templates for
reproducibility and store config files
and a source version control so it's
discoverable and can be audited
automating infrastructure with a CI CD
pipeline means any changes to your
configuration can be automatically
tested and deployed by adopting IAC
created Junction was able to boost their
ability to skip Google Cloud deployment
manager is an IAC service that automates
the creation and management of Google
cloud resources using a declarative ml
base configuration format from
test prod you can build repeatable
environments with compute networks
storage databases users and permissions
using simple configuration files for
more complex architectures that you plan
to reuse you can even break your
configuration into templates which are a
separate file that defines a set of
resources you can reuse templates across
different deployments which creates
consistency across complex deployment in
this example this configuration file
specifies resources from compute engine
and bakery along with firewall rules to
provide access now critter Junction can
use the G Cloud SDK to create preview
update and delete deployments meanwhile
the Google Cloud console shows them all
of their deployed infrastructure and a
hierarchical view whether they need to
do this one time ten times or a thousand
times this allows some to have granular
control over the lifecycle of their
resources for example they were able to
produce costs by running a script every
morning that brings up hundreds of
machines and every evening to use that
same script to scale it back down and
because no one likes drastic changes to
existing DevOps workflows you can use
other IAC tools like terraform chef and
puppet to deploy resources in Google
Cloud and on Prem from one place by
removing manual steps from their
infrastructure provisioning critter
Junction has been able to get
consistency and speed of deployment in
their staging QA and production
environments at scale stay tuned to
follow their journey and remember always
be architecting
[Music]